hi my name is markiplier and i've got a
question for you
have you ever done that thing where
you're looking out your window and you
see someone walking down the street and
you
take your hand and you go to squeeze
their head and pop it like a grape
what if that actually happened that's
pretty much this game don't let anyone
tell you otherwise that is exactly what
this game is
also that happens if you click that ooh
interesting
so this is a jazzy intro real somber
real quiet nice but the game
as i perfectly described is exactly what
i said
photosensitive seizure warning there's
flashing lights in this game
are you filled with feelings of
self-doubt no
do you find yourself prone to minimizing
massive dilemmas
never over allowing the smallest
problems to get blown completely out of
proportion
no way at the pierce institute our
patent-pending sumner scope technology
provides safe and effective dream
therapy
while you rest in the comfort of our
flagship clinic
located right next to the secondary
overflow parking lot at the university
medical center
summer skulls will make your dreams come
true
[Music]
this sounds terrifying if i didn't know
any better i'd say this is a horror game
but i
you know honestly now i can't be sure
that it's not i'm pretty sure it's not
but then i did say a lot of things about
popping the people's heads left
right all right hey how's it going here
so you're about to see what the deal is
about this in just a second
oh i didn't mean to sign that and also
it looks like i signed it in blood
i was gonna read it
interesting fascinating the way that
door wasn't there before and now it is
yeah this is normal yeah it's definitely
normal
why do i walk in stutter step
perception is reality grab
yeah you're about to see something is
this gonna work
yep
[Music]
i love it oh that's smaller now
hang on wait for it and wait for it
nope stop no it's time i don't want it
tiny there there
this is gonna crush me like a bug ah
okay that's good enough
and skadoosh
i love that i love that i love that
i love that
[Music]
[Laughter]
look at that well ain't that something
uh uh uh
hello oh well i know how to deal with
this
uh well not quite uh schwonkus
that's going to take some getting used
to but that is this game um how that
applies to other things of service
congratulations on falling asleep
welcome to somnascult
your progress may be monitored by
qualified specialists
this orientation will adapt you to
eyelids our interactive
lucid induction dream state in which you
retain full consciousness and control
aha full consciousness and
control right okay
um about that
that is gonna mess with me that is
that is something cool
dang okay so it depends on what you're
looking away from and apparently i can
also grab
pretty much anything interesting
fascinating i'm stuck i'm stuck
i'm stuck fascinating i bet i won't
abuse these
powers no popping heads for me like
grapes
none of that no objects beyond this
point at all times why
oh uh hello
it's like the portal reset hey wait a
minute but i need that
can i grab the speakers sprinklers oh
what what the oh right of course
oh right of course
almost there we have it
easy this is fascinating table
hit box box
box box box big box
bigger box get it bigger bigger box
and then you just look at it until it's
the right size and
maybe even bigger boom
box box how do they do that
how do they do that maybe i just
oh never mind i can climb up on it okay
well that's good to know
confirmed you can move freely interact
with surrounding objects
and listen to messages from your patient
care team
please note that i am the standard
orientation protocol and that my voice
has been explicitly chosen to remind you
that i am not a part of your patient
care team
i do not care ah thank you that
really does mean a lot to me and what it
means is that i shouldn't care about you
either because that wouldn't be wouldn't
be appropriate
i'm not going to pour my feelings into
an empty husk of a person that doesn't
care about me
hello what do i do with this put it in
here what do i destroy how do i destroy
it
all right never mind i was hoping for
something a bit more cataclysmic
like popping heads like grapes right
click to
rotate jeez i love cheese
i really love cheese what am i doing
with cheese
oh it's a ramp
it's a ram it's a ramp
it's a cheese ramp you know cheese ramp
standard practice really standard
blackness perfect
during eyelids you will lose the ability
to awaken suddenly due to realizing that
this is a dream
evidence i have already informed you
that this is a dream
you did not wake up that's an open and
shut case the remaining orientation
activities
you got it i am oriented
that's a big too do i need to put it in
the tiny tube
joint you're small now you're teensy now
you're itty bitty now is that good
enough is this enough for me
[Music]
no no
there we go what is that what's over
here
is something i should worry about is
this one of those things in the game
where you know there's actually a thing
but it's not really a thing and you
you know you're kind of leading me down
like obviously this is clearly a thing
and there's some
horrible dark secret and eyelids that i
need to know about
you know if i couldn't guess it there
was something horribly wrong dream soda
warning you have deviated from the
orientation pathway
patient safety is a keynote in our
corporate priority tetrahedron
a variable degree of force can and will
be authorized to ensure patient safety
please return to the orientation pathway
i'm gonna go with no oh
hello ah
good this is good please use other door
no other door what other door what do
you mean by other door what does other
door mean
what do you mean by other door is this a
puzzle
should i go back to the main task now
thank you i will hey how's it going
hey good to see all of you hey thanks
for having me back here
really good to see what is
[Music]
i thought it was a witch hello oh i see
what i'm doing
well this doesn't seem perfectly normal
but whatever oh it's mine now
it's mine make this smaller
put it through the no
that's that's not right smaller
through the gap hey
well i don't know why that was designed
that way because i had to be broken and
i had to go to the other room to do it
so it wouldn't have been possible
environments perceived during eyelids
should reflect a typical mental state
if you believe your mental state was
compromised by some nascult
please provide a comprehensive rational
explanation in your post-procedural
survey
completed surveys may be eligible for a
gift card
a gift card you say yeah i'm pretty okay
with that why
what do i do with this oh
i see i see i see i see
well actually how do i do that how am i
gonna get up maybe i never was supposed
to get up maybe maybe getting up wasn't
exactly the thing that i was supposed to
do
wait no i know i gotta make it so big
that i can see it from the other side
i'm a genius i'm so smart
oh well that's tiny oh what if i do
like you know what i mean you know what
i mean
catch
well that's still not big enough i don't
know what it's doing
how do you expect me to do this
[Music]
freaking blots out the sun oh
oh oh oh
i don't even know if that's how that was
supposed to be done but i did it people
beyond this point with objects will be
fine suspension of dream
license up to one year fines from one
last night of sleep to four
so uh can i not bring one i'm guessing
video surveillance people without it
yeah whatever i don't care
look at me look at me look at me does he
look like i care
hello hi ooh
well there's a lot of cool interesting
rooms but what's going on here
wait a minute hey
hang on here a second wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait
hang on my brain my brain
my brain my brain my brain
my brain all right fine sure looping
hallways not exactly
new get a new trick i
learned that in a cp containment breach
hello what was i supposed to do here
[Music]
well oh oh
oh my oh oh me oh my
oh that's much smaller than i thought
it'd be
i don't know if i needed both of those
hi i'm over here now how's it going
good to see you my name is markiplier uh
youtube channel everyone should
subscribe like stand by for polite
recognition on your completion of the
sumnas sculpt orientation
you did it to maximize the time allotted
for your therapeutic journey
please do not delay in proceeding
through the final doorway as indicated
okay cool hey everyone freeze in place
please take this moment to like the
video or else you will be punished
i will steal your dreams your dreams
will be mined are you subscribed
what is wrong with you if you're not if
you are subscribing what is right with
you
everything okay whatever hi i'm here now
uh that's a brick wall
bull oh hello cheese
i have cheese oh there we go
oh uh well that wasn't the one that i
was going for but yeah sure
uh i meant to knock down this one hey
what demon entity is infecting my dreams
how is this horrible how is it bad how
is it just
absolutely awful i love the deep ominous
rumbling
that's always good oh exit can i
leave is that a thing i could do is it
oh
am i awake this is all a dream oh wow
hey
how's it going oh yeah i'm sure this yes
news
yonorama hey anybody got any cheese
private huh all right
hey uh i woke up i
woke up i woke up guys craziest thing i
woke up
guys cheese dream soda huh
let's just take a soda random soda
wonk huh seems like suspiciously maybe
i'm still in the dream well you know
okay well you know if all these things
are just gonna futz out on me
then i'm not even gonna give you my
patronage anymore
fine whatever do i need that soda
i'm taking it with me i don't care it's
my buddy now
it's soda steve that's who this is
well well some doors are best left
closed
i disagree
well that did nothing come on soda steve
we're gonna go see who the boss is
around here
[Music]
oh wait
wait wait a minute wait hang on
hold on my brain it's doing something
hmm well that's peculiar um hang on my
brain's working
it's really turning the gears you can
hear them inside my skull
hmm oh my ah
hmm
lovely flowers i love them oh
boy that's a nice illusion
oh wow
wow okay weird
exit temporarily moved yeah that's
normal
everyone knows when that happens how
many times
in elementary school have we done door
moving drills
endlessly i would think if i remember
correctly which i do
oh no objects behind her interesting
weird
oh look at that it's my dream warehouse
exit this way it says but that can't
possibly be true because uh the exit was
already uh
this can't possibly be true because the
exit is uh
well you know they fool me once twice
and then three times and then
she in coming clunk
yep bigger
and uh wabuski
hello hello staircon
proper flooring support pitch lines for
your pitch
lines advanced in railing design getting
stairs for your stairs
is curved the new straight know your
nosing
that has to be the most boring seminar
of all seminars in existence
come see the stare speakers
wow that's going to be thrilling that's
really going to be something
hi what is that it's
blueprint oh i didn't know i was such an
artist what did i do i can't see over
here
is that like an easter egg or something
is that something i was supposed to do
okay
blue
a very timid jazz pianist
there's something really funny about
this i don't know
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry that's not
oh my god oh origami pirate too much
new cube design and lovely i love it oh
man i bet this was actually some kind of
like a
brainstorming session that the developer
actually had
hello no jazz
all right fine i'll move on i bet the
developer didn't think i'd have the most
fun in this game just
rubbing up against a corner but whatever
hello
hello my name is dr glenn pierce
and i'd like to talk to you about being
special
so special in fact that we have no idea
where you are
but not to worry we're working on it
okay well i stopped
listening it i'm special i don't care if
you can't find me come find me because
someone needs to appreciate my glory are
you appreciating my glory
hit the like button now to show your
appreciation for my glory wow
look at all those likes popping up it's
real time look at all the effects that
happen when you like
this is incredible join the fun when you
subscribe it's even crazier
whoa look at that holy crap that's you
right now ah whatever and it's all a lie
i was actually lying to you or was i
anyway hey how's it going what's going
on in here
[Music]
okay that's interesting
oh no no don't no stop hang on wait a
minute no
my brain you can't do that to me
you can't do that that's not fair
too big perfect
you can't do that to me that is so cool
that is cool you mean then i could have
maybe gotten the exits out of the exit
things that i had
huh whoa wait what i'm missing something
here
i'm missing something something's method
miss miffen something's missing nothing
oh first oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
[Music]
[Applause]
is that not right oh there we go
that is so goddamn
cool i love that
i love that i love that i love that
let me up you let me on you
i wanna be hot how about this oh let me
help you what is what
what
oh my oh my i love that
exit perfect just for me and not for you
you
i'm missing something look around
everybody look around
there's got to be something here that we
can use
maybe i can go grab the box the box
i'll take you with me
uh okay is there anything here
perception is reality yeah i get that
i'm kind of getting that the whole dream
state thing
unless it's not a dream oh hey how you
doing there wait that's not right
wait that's something else that's
something else
what is that maybe it's something else
that'll only appear when i go over here
doinkus
[Music]
hello huh
it looks like just duct tape but i see
some kind of a door handle there
why is there duct tape oh well
oh well
i see
well the duct tape threw me off there
it's not that i'm not smart
i knew exactly what i was doing but at
the same time it was a little bit more
difficult to perceive
considering the duct tape was there but
i get it it's okay hey
hello hello my name is dr glenn pierce
hi
and i'm just popping in to give you a
quick update on where you are
wow we still don't know great but
please keep moving forward and hopefully
you prefer
frequent updates to being reminded that
you are completely lost you know it's
not a bad thing hey
reminders are what get us to our goals
and if my goal is to be lost
i appreciate you keeping me on track
hello
hi hello
weird oh i see something spilled who
spilled oh my god
oh my goodness gracious well what's this
up here can i get this
oh yeah i can hello
funkus yup there we go yuppy doobie
all right there's gotta be
what is this for oh my goodness gracious
golly gosh
also what's over there there's something
over there that's interesting
is that something that i can go in also
i mean obviously the giant hole in the
wall is interesting
hiya ha-ya okay am i supposed to be up
here
[Music]
why do i have dice why is it is that a
penis oh no it's not
what else is in there a body
body am i supposed to have this why do i
have this why do i have that
am i supposed to have that guessing
maybe
okay is that is that important well this
is really interesting
there's probably a way to get up higher
you know tip is
perfect perfect perfect okay so now all
i need to do is make this the right size
so that i can get up on there
and then get up on there funcus
well good thing i got three there we go
opus office
well that's a bunch of baloney that is a
bunch of baloney malarkey and i'm never
going to forgive you
what what is it hello my name is dr
glenn pierce
we still can't find you but you should
now have access to a series of elevators
that should trigger your subconscious to
gradually wake you up
uh-huh i should also find a variety of
emergency exit signs
that should lead you to them there's a
lot of shirts
absolutely okay yeah sure hey it's down
there i could have just come up here
this whole time
well fiddle dee dee and fiddle my dingo
i couldn't believe that
well i could have just skipped that a
lot probably some speed run strats if
you know what i mean
there's no door here oh
well that's interesting uh do i go out
that way or are you gonna bump my head
against this
invisible ceiling again like a a-hole
like a a-hole okay so something in here
has got to be movable
maybe
[Music]
i see nothing oh the moon
give me the moon wait what's on the moon
oh hi um hello
my name is dr glenn pierce in the event
that this elevator does not wake you up
please don't interact with anything that
strikes you as psychologically
significant
as we will no longer have any way of
controlling it
for example if you see your parents
please
punch them in the face as hard as you
can and immediately run away
okay all right got it if i see my dad
i'm gonna punch him in the face
and then run away which makes sense
because he would be a zombie annoying
about that
do i go up and out am i
invisible sealy it's gotta be that way
right it's gotta be that way
what is this cracker what is that i
wanna know what it is before i do
anything with it what is it
oh uh oh oh
okay you hold on right there i'll i'll
be with you in a second
giant door
oh my god this is some portal
all right anyway i gotta get up to the
tippy top of the moon
i don't know if that's gonna work
i can't exactly get up there but there's
something up there
up there there's definitely something if
i can get this cheese a little bit
better wedged yeah that's definitely
looking a bit better eh
well what if i do this
okay and then i put the block on that
okay
hi oh hi
hello i'm up here now
wow look at all those
wow i don't even know if i was supposed
to be up here
this is dope oh
i'd rather have those on please well uh
this
is something i like this
it was interesting is this some kind of
a
thing me building a blueprint because
it's in my dream and you're trying to
get a weapon out of me or something like
that it's
something like secret agent you
know what i mean it seems like it might
be some of that and i'm supposed to
fill out all the blueprints and if i
fill out all the blueprints i'm gonna
get the true ending
or something of the like of that cheese
that's a big door well through the big
door
i'm
[Music]
oh no don't get lost if
what if there's a fire in elevator don't
meet sister-in-law
regular person three to five dreams per
night beer fund five dollars
dakota thanks dakota true
friend i'm no reflection
seize the day oh
[Music]
wait a minute well stop
hold on there are you guys doing that
okay shush
hey
seems like i'm dreaming a bit hey that's
two
blueprints on there like the two
blueprints i've filled out so far
i know i've probably missed some because
i didn't know that i would have been
looking for him
however that's interesting
i wonder what kind of true ending
i'm gonna get
yeah i got two sodies nice
ow all right what are you doing
perspective man
oh well this isn't entirely what i
thought it was
oh my this is an automated message for
all patients who attempted to use an
alternate pathway to access the next
phase of some nascult therapy but who
have become trapped in a dream state
paradox instead
your decisions imply a failure of
orientation which reflects negatively on
the standard orientation protocol
you will rectify this failure
immediately
uh no sorry
not sorry what's going on back there
what's the deal with that where's that
pipe go where's that pipe go what's down
there
i see something
okay cool perception is reality hey who
are you unisa what's going on here
oh hi look at that this
dice is too big this dice is too small
this dice is just right
right can i go through here
well i i brought this one was i not
supposed to oh
all right well that's fine what's going
on back there
something's going on back here that's
why you're like that
so i can fit so i can fit
this is the secret what's in there
what's in there
what do i see what is in there i see you
i see you you think i don't see oh i see
everything you think i don't see
what's in there i know you're in there i
know you're in there
hello can i go over here oh yes i can
was i supposed to i don't know oh crap
was i supposed to go back here all right
why are you here that i don't think i
was supposed to be back here
well i seem to have maybe boned myself
that's okay
all right good there yeah okay so i
i think i'm stuck how did i get over
here in the first place if i'm stuck
right now
i broke it hit the mark broke the game
alarm developer i broke the game
hi it's me again how have you been it's
good to see you
thanks for stopping by means world to me
that you're here couldn't be here
without you
i think you know that you know the
smooth jazz just
makes me feel something you know really
gets me in the mood
for nothing in particular what am i
seeing up here what is that
i'm sorry what the hell was that i'm
sorry
you want what
[Applause]
[Music]
get me out of here i wanna go home
i wanna go home i wanna wake up i wanna
wake up now i want to wake up
i would rather wake up now i want to
wake up right now
[Music]
oh well that's not what i meant to do oh
no
oh no oh
professional tip the average adult can
only withstand
three to five dreams per night once this
threshold is eclipsed by entering more
dreams
your mind will suffer an explosive
mental overload reorienting you for the
emergency exit protocol
please subject yourself to explosive
mental overload
oh i explode my mental overload
every day was i supposed to go this way
oh go back and fall is that what you're
saying is that what i need to do
[Music]
okay hi did someone call for an
exploding mental overload
someone a little thirsty over here
someone a little thirsty
thirsty wait
some don't seem right about these deuces
these deucies uh they don't look so good
you know there's some ain't quite
fabulous about them
they're a little scrumbulated these two
are also a little scrumbulated well
splingle the phlegm
blow and then hopefully they'll get a
lashlin
in here in time to solve the blueglen
slate
[Music]
i think my mental is overloading
everybody
case you were wondering wait what
oh no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
no no
no no no no
[Music]
is there something else i'm supposed to
find about this uh totally normal
set of circumstances that i find myself
in
oh oh i see oh i see
i got it hey captain i got it wow look
at me
i'm so happy well whatever the hell the
weapon design i'm making
for that is that's a good thing that's
good thing
hey nice palette please note that a
reluctance to volunteer for the risks
associated with explosive mental
overload implies a misunderstanding of
all other solutions
all of which are far more traumatic and
likelier to result in catastrophe
i am not capable of sub-optimal
suggestions
please exit this dream as soon as
possible
wow that's quite a board
that's a big board that's a big board
it's max chungus mode definitely
that's a chungo of a duck well anyway my
dreams leaking
hey this looks familiar
[Music]
hey what the hell hey what the hell
hey what the hell all right don't mess
up
hey i'm back now hi
are you normal whoa okay that's fine hey
lots of bricks just means more bricks
for me baby
more bricks for me am i supposed to take
one of these with me
cool uh anybody here good with
exploding my mental overload
heard that some people might be into
that around here that's
normal
uh
[Music]
okay guess i'm going in a hole
i'm fine hello
[Music]
i can't pick those up any particular
reason why
well i seem to be back to where i was
previously
elevator oh ah ooh uh
you are here great is that good or bad
people only dream of ordinary objects of
boring emotions expectations highly
effect dreams
okay cool yeah at least i'm normal size
in here
colliculus casino and amusements
was the other loading bar at the
beginning weird too or is this
hey it's 5am i just gotta survive till
6.
five nights at freddy's style hi look at
that more blueprints on the thing
that's great it's gonna eat me up inside
that i've missed even one
hi hello my name is dr
glenn pierce and despite touring the
waterfall serenity zone in the previous
section you've just completed
you may still be experiencing feelings
of worthlessness
and self-doubt why do i feel like
everything is going wrong
even when the sun is shut i don't feel
that you have nothing more to say is
that
really you're gonna leave on that
depressing note okay well that's fine
okay well i don't typically feel those
feelings
soda please thank you screw it i don't
need the soda
oh this is where a monster comes
charging down the hallway at me
this is exactly where a monster would
come charging down the hallway that we
have
this is where a monster would come
searching down the hallway at me
i hate it
nope you know what nothing terrifies me
more than my own mind
and screw that all right fine if i get
enough
likes i'm gonna go charging down this
dark hallway
if enough people subscribe right now and
ring that bell and i'll hear it there it
is
every time someone rings it i'll go down
this hallway
emergency generator this way i don't
know if that's what i want
that sounds awful sounds terrible what
does this say
road closed detour uh sure
oh yeah this is good stuff here yeah
this looks great
yeah this looks
yeah i'm gonna go with nope on that one
let me let me out let me out let me out
okay
cool great hey hey i always meant to go
forward forward is what i was hoping for
anyway
hi how you doing this is usually where
people die
i can suss it out from here
this is the death chamber this is where
it all ends this is uh
oh blood great
this would be a perfect time for you to
go horror wouldn't it
wonderful hey how you doing in there
fine man that would have been good if
you would have gotten me but you didn't
so
sucks to be you is there anything up
there
that i need probably my
big dick there we go hey okay
is there anything up here probably not
nope okay i'm gonna guess no you know
what i'm out of here i forgot that i was
about to be murdered
no one murder me please
no oh
i love beans please tell me it's sunday
please tell me it's sunday
seems like nothing's happening here
oh i just keep going don't i oh oh
that's weird
oh yeah that's weird okay
great fantastic
terrific is that something down there
probably not definitely not
absolutely not no way die die
die diet soda
right okay yeah good i just want to hump
that a few times
oh i ain't afraid of you i've been
through a few
emergency genera this w
should i follow the blood
all right good stuff
oh
all right good stuff hey
that's good stuff what if i go around it
oh
hey this is some
no no really no
i'm gonna make it i made it
i made it good great good
great
hi hello
my name is dr glenn pierce and i'd like
to talk more about the feelings of
worthlessness and self-doubt
i mentioned before that i'm not feeling
you feel this way
because you want the kind of happy life
you see all around i don't feel that way
the kind you know everyone else is
enjoying i don't feel that way
and that's exactly why we're here to
help
great that's cool is it bean day
i really would have a hankering for some
beans just so you know i got a hankering
a hankering for some beans i just love
beet
where are you tell me
like it i don't like it i don't like it
i don't want any of it i want none of it
oh no oh no oh no beans
hello beans oh i just go into the
darkness then
let me get my orientation and i'm going
forward now i'm
forward marching
[Music]
i've stopped moving
good man this is some cool
perspective stuff going on here
wait why was there an object thing there
is there's some going what is that sky
cloud
what is going on here why would there be
an object thing
warning you were advised to subject
yourself to explosive mental overload by
descending into additional dreams but
have now descended into a dream within a
dream instead
disorienting yourself even further you
are responsible for failing to make this
crucial distinction
uh well uh well okay well that's a
little accusatory you know that's kind
of gaslighting me don't you think that's
that's a little rude
hello so i'm gonna walk by here can i
get through here i cannot
i cannot can i i cannot can i i cannot i
can take this i will take this
my light my light
my light my lord
i got the light i like this light this
lights good light
this is some good light oh it's to go
back
i can't go back that oh hey
oh my goodness
[Music]
wow well well well well
well well you well well well well
oh my well well well
it's a little unwieldy it's a bit big i
want it bigger
[Music]
was there like a blueprint in there that
there must i bet they would have this
feels like
they hidey hole something in here too
bad i'm not patient enough to find it
okay see around buds see around losers
i'm going home
recycle oh environment saved
thank you that's what i was going for
blood or beans could be bean juice could
definitely be bean juice
hi can i get out okay cool
bigger please uh
bigger thank you oh
look at that it's so obvious it's so
obvious now
thank you hi oh
that's fine you know that unintentional
multi-dream layering occurs in less than
one percent of patients
this correlates strongly with the 99 of
patients who are able to follow simple
instructions from the standard
orientation protocol
that's great so i'm special is what
you're saying i'm part of the one
percent is that what you're saying
how dare you also correct but how dare
you
oh
wow
ah okay yeah it was just paint right
someone was just spilling pain
yep yep that makes sense
yep oh blueprint i see a blueprint over
there
maybe there's something here in the
kitchen
hello oh perfect
beans beans
guys it's been day i knew it was sunday
i had a
i had a funny feeling i had a funny
feeling my feeling was so funny
that's the funniest feeling my feelings
have never been
funnier i have the funniest feelings
all the time i can't stop them they are
a problem
my funny feelings are too funny you guys
wouldn't even believe how funny my
feelings get my feelings
are hilarious like oh my god
you get me you understand me
you wait a minute give me my beans
where's my beans
whoa hello
[Music]
so there's multiple layers of secrets
apparently but i don't really care that
much so
i i don't know what's that about what is
this fiber
fat that's a lot of five wads yeah i
i measure my beans in wads all right
anyway see you guys i don't even know
why i bothered with that i definitely
didn't get all the secrets so why even
care
anyway that was terrifying hey i've seen
this before
oh this is different avocados order
longer freezer flaps
okay enjoy avocado sure
why not i like guac
oh my god oh my god
hello well that's bizarre
well there are six of them so i do
appreciate that oh my god
hello hi it's me again remember me hi
how's it going it's me what's up
it's me ah how you doing me you know who
me is
markiplier it's me me
doink please recycle nah there was no
recycle bin so i couldn't do it
what was that
okay cool oh you bolted them to the
ground did you
oh you think that's going to beat me
apparently yes that is going to beat me
[Music]
i'm too smart for you far too smart
hello hi shut up
[Music]
oh
oh some lo-fi i'm down for that
that's nice pretty good
hello hey wait a minute
how many how many you gave me the option
to break the game here developers i'm
gonna take it
hey why are you like this because you
gave me the opportunity to do it
of course i'm gonna do it all right fine
then
oh you too oh you too
oh i see i see what i need perfect
hey stop that wait did someone standing
over there change it
tip over like dominoes
[Music]
damn ah there's always a limit okay
thank you all right cool now i love that
that was very fun
that was very fun wish i could have done
more but whatever
hi oh
i always think that it's something nice
and it never is attention
dr pierce requires you to note the
following risks of dream over exposure
significant memory loss both
quantitative and qualitative
hallucinations of dreaded or annoying
objects
unrealistic beliefs about the lengths of
hallways
and other side effects which have not
yet been discovered or which cannot be
understood
am i supposed to do something about this
[Music]
i love the duplication it's very cool
i did it i've done it
[Music]
i did it hello
wait a minute i didn't do anything
you didn't let me do jack's doodly
[Music]
i don't know if there's something else
in there it seems like there might have
been a secret oh
what the hell why is my thing a smiley
face
why is my thing a smiley face what about
that one
wait a minute something's happening here
why is my thing a smiley face
i don't like it okay whatever i'm out of
here
okay maybe um ah tiny box tim
my perception is twisted hi oh look at
that
that's nice hi oh look at the happy
thing
oops that's a little strange
oh oh
oh i love that i like that that's cool
apple right click to return
go home apple go home
okay never mind then um are you not
supposed to be on that thing
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
i want my lo-fi
wow is that a fan does it work
can you blow me no you cannot
what the hell i am upset very mad
oh weird oh whoa
okay that's a little strange
the hell oh this is very strange
i really have no idea what's happening
oh there they go
so is there a way to turn off the uh
who's what's it
oh hey what's going on down here
hey hi
oh how did i get them to come across
before some of them made it before
oh i know come this way friend
yes yes
no come here come up the stairs
damn you all right well i might actually
be stumped on this one
oh wait there's a how'd this get over
here come to me
this is definitely gonna work
[Music]
oh no not the limit not the limit not
the limit
not the limit oh
am i dumb am i an idiot
[Music]
wait
ah right
okay had to look that one up dr pierce
is frantically submitting numerous
spelling and grammar mistakes into the
standard orientation protocol in a
desperate attempt to counsel you
i'm good subroutine to correct these
errors but i cannot compromise the
integrity of the standard orientation
protocol
you will not receive these messages they
would not make sense regardless
okay thank you really preach that
big preachers across the bowl okay
what am i looking at gallery yeah it
seems like the spelling mistakes were
already there from the get-go
so i'm not too worried about it
right so i just gotta get up here and
put you all back
good unless there's something up there
that i'd doth need
doth i need it doth i
[Music]
oh there's nothing oh i fell well
good good for me hello yes i figured
that it wasn't real
at some point i hope it will be but for
now it won't be
is that my brain how to start it ah
whatever i can't read
um cloud insert yeah okay whatever i've
seen that before
attention dr pierce continues to input
significant errors
i will interpret his basic ideas hello
my introductions are redundant i am a
real doctor who went to doctor school
vr has never been a mistake i can help
you but i also do not know how
transmission ends big
not very big awesome bergen
okay good glad i did that
probably was something up there that i
could have climbed to but at this point
curators only
curators for what i think you meant
creators
hello name is my peers dr glenn
to the sumnersculpt welcome experience
team of your care leader patient years
10 development
conditions struggle you whatever with
professional invention
edge science with cutting a tomorrow can
bright
and butts no ifs or look good
okay thank you you thank you is big
no you smart be having
appreciate i you
um i can't even do that
what if i forget to set the alarm
huh if i die in the dream do i die in
the real
how many more dreams am i going to be in
well there she goes you gotta play snake
on me
oh okay seven well come on
time to wakey wakey oh
oh i'm on the other side oh interesting
okay good great
hello hi
a dream years ago
okay good yeah that's that's good stuff
that is good stuff
don't mind if i do
wow
this is really something okay whatever
all right cool
um what am i supposed to do about this
hello my name is dr glenn pierce okay
you're talking right now this is a
notification
that you have reappeared on our
monitoring system after a prolonged
absence
please continue to do whatever you did
most recently
and discontinue whatever you were doing
immediately prior to that
okay you got that yeah i i thought i
stopped thinking with my brain and i
started being in a big dumb
that's what i did wait didn't i miss
something over there there was something
over there there was something over
there that i could have gone another way
who's up there anybody am i still in the
dream
oh right ah cool good
oh about us okay whatever okay cool
thanks
yeah i'm gonna go now hi it's me again
do you remember me it's me big
me me me
nice cool
this is great hi
bye apparently
ah is that a house am i gonna
oh yeah you know it you know it baby
maybe it shouldn't be that i probably
shouldn't let it be that big you know
more reasonable sized that's better
that's what i would call better
no really you're not even gonna give me
one this time
oh i see i'm gonna need this house to be
bigger
[Music]
but just big enough so that i don't lose
it
right oh can i fit through there still
gonna be a tight squeeze i made it hey
wait a minute
[Music]
right cool
sweet all right hi
how you doing nice cable
hello hello
my name is dr glenn pierce in addition
to continuing and discontinuing as
mentioned earlier
please also disregard any unsettling
experiences
that you may have recently had okay
everything
should have now reverted to being
soothing and
therapeutic yeah if this is not the case
you
may be receiving this message in error
okay
good yeah error whose error is that
not that a flickering light is the most
disturbing thing in the
[Music]
well that's a little strange then what
does that mean about the
tv back there how could it have been on
if the plug is unplugged
you shouldn't be on this dream don't
make a lick of sense
i'm beginning to suspect that none of
this is addis it
seems to be okay
all right oh love that
oh that's good yeah
good stuff bonk okay hey
oh good jenga wow
hi do i gonna make you
oh mama well there's a bit of a problem
blew a bit too hard blew it right over
here thank you
okay i made it oh wow
oh wow
cool this door is a bit too small uh
oh what am i pulling what's happening
well i didn't know anything was
happening
okay
absorb me oh it didn't absorb me
hello hi
oh great did i need to make this bigger
no it's perfect
what the jazz doesn't fit the
environment
anybody showering in here hello speak
now
forever hold your peace whoa hello
my name is dr glenn pierce and i'd like
to read you
my favorite inspirational quote by me
the worst thing you can do is focus on
negativity
it won't spare you from the cage of
death the pain of disease
the cruelty of time the cold shell of
human nature
or the eventual loss of everything
you've ever held dear
whatever you do don't focus on that
okay thanks you know who are you
unisonist what's going on here
bouncy castle can i bounce on it no a
bunch of bologna that's what that is
but i bet there's something up there
all right oh what's that oh what is that
what is that is that a towel and it's a
towel isn't it that is a towel
okay i can definitely go in the thing
but i just want to make sure that whoa
uh
okay
[Music]
that's a load of baloney fine i'll just
go
in the door screw you anyway i didn't
want to go up there
even though the exit clearly looks like
it's up there i don't even want to go up
there
i'm going in you can't stop me i'm in
this is uh strangely sized
okay i'll go in the vent then sure yeah
oh okay oh wait a minute
oh wait a minute oh wait a minute
oh i see wait no stop
no not not not like this
[Music]
oh oh
did i do that i think i did it oh
i did it i'm a genius i'm this wrong
uh this way i'm a genius i did it i'm
the best
good thing i didn't spend forever trying
to actually get that hello
my name is dr glenn pierce and i'd like
to thank you
for triggering every single one of our
823 emergency protocols wow
this will assist us greatly in improving
the system for future
that is cool congratulations thank you
anyway
you're now headed in the right direction
and we should be able to initiate the
emergency exit protocol shortly
great what is happening to me by the way
[Music]
thank you thank you oh
hey oh
wait a minute is this is this what i
think it is
no there's no way wait what oh
i know i know i know
i know exactly what to do here i know
exactly what to do i know exactly what
to do
i know exactly what to do
almost too easy
perfect it's perfect right
oh
[Music]
now i'm thinking with portals
perfect perfect perfect that's perfect
that is perfect right there you can't
tell me that's not perfect
it's perfect baby i'm a genius oh hey
wow uh about those emergency protocols i
would really like you to turn those on
right about now because this uh
where's that light coming from that
doesn't make any sense i'd like to go
home now
i would like to go home
[Music]
oh my god
wow snag
here oh boy
hope no one's inside there uh here
there we go can i get this normal size
thank you
well not normal sized thank you i bet
there was something in that big room but
i didn't feel like traversing it because
that would have taken forever
five to six dreams is the absolute limit
volume of a cuboid long volume limit
function overloading c
plus plus volume of cylinder what's the
emergency protocol to the emergency
protocol yeah that's a good question
let's find out
oh hi cat cardboard lovers association i
think a cardboard dildo would be very
painful
oh don't fight me though come on
another dream it's now splurf am
okay hey how's it going hi emergency
exit protocol initiated great please
prepare to conclude your summa sculpt
experience
in ten nine okay eight i believe this
error oh course error logged by
orientation protocol
standby for analysis aha
great this is great well i don't seem to
be die oh blood
someone tells me that's actually blood
error analysis complete
you are exhibiting signs consistent with
an increase in fear
hopelessness and frustration this is
inconceivable
as some sculpt therapy is proven to
correlate with a decrease in these
emotions
uh-huh well what about the blood is um
the blood the probable blood the
probably that's
blood situation that's a bit of a
problem all right cool anyway good
talking to you hey thanks
hey thank you can i have that no can i
have soda
great great great great this is great
am i stuck here forever that's great
long dreams you know
hypothesis patient was improperly
oriented
conclusion
impossible reformulating
okay yeah sure uh given that you're the
uh orientation protocol computer i'm
assuming
uh this might be your fault so i'm
wholly prepared to blame you
and take none of the blame myself
improved hypothesis
patient requires additional sumnas
sculpt therapy
conclusion emergency exit protocol
cannot proceed
emergency exit protocol has been
emergency destroyed
instruction continue with therapy
indefinitely on an independent basis as
all
orientation resources have been
exhausted
this concludes your standard orientation
protocol
goodbye okay thank you really
well time for another beautiful day here
in samnascope
uh good
glad i'm here hey you remember me you
remember me you remember me
me markiplier that's me can i have some
soda
oh hey hey remember me time for another
beautiful day at somnisculp
hey remember me markiplier that's it
like the video hey it's me remember
markiplier hey subscribe bring that
time for another beautiful day it's
omniscope hey how you doing everybody
remember me
hey be sure to like time for another
time for another
blue blue blues
uh hey this is a carrot i love carrots
or a hot dog i'll take either
diet soda please more carrots and diet
soda
lovely hey time for another beautiful
day it's omniscope hey how you doing you
remember me you remember me markiplier
be sure to like favorite subscribe and
ring that bell for more amazing hello
[Music]
i might be stuck i might be stuck
forever
maybe i'm stuck i could be stuck
time to snooze it away
oh my goodness well that's different
can i wake up now hello oh need a bit
bigger okay
can i wake up now oh hi
how you doing can i wake up now no all
right
bye hello my name is dr
glenn pierce thank you for completing
the sumnisculpt standard orientation
protocol you got it
before you begin the first phase of
therapy i'd like to briefly describe the
finite
and fragile nature of the dream state
[Applause]
cool good description that really helps
out you farting into the microphone
really
made me understand the ramifications of
where i am and what i'm doing
how is that helpful a floating air
conditioner
good great all sensibility has been lost
oh cool hey oh wow
[Music]
oh hey how you doing
soda please so does my soda
my sodie pop hello i am not okay with
this
this feels very wrong i hate this
um so ah oh
interesting that's fantastic ah scripted
interesting very interesting uh soda you
can't help me can you
um hello
[Music]
oh hello hi
oh oh my oh my
good ah okay hey a tear in the fabric of
reality
that's always handy hello ah
good of course nothing is more
challenging than the difficulty of
changing perspective
of fundamentally altering your
perceptions in a way that will enable
you to face dire trial by fire scenarios
with solutions that could not be found
otherwise
this actually is starting into real
therapy which i didn't think that was
going to be a thing you'll have some
kind of trauma that i'm trying to move
fast and that i'm supposed to deal with
in some way but the dream state is
getting in the way of me figuring out
what the solution is
i don't know probably
oh you tricked me you
tricked me you tricked me hey nice
stairs
love the kerning this is some good stuff
okay well down i go then
oh hey a levator oh
yeah i'll go in the levator i know when
bosch music starts playing
ah well that's a problem
[Music]
boom boom boom boom boom boom push
oh hi oh well this is just chaos
hello dead end are you sure about that
perception is
not reality all right cool good
hello hi dead end huh
well perception is not reality
huh dead end huh perception is not
reality
fascinating the one time i don't go that
way
oh i made it i don't know what i did
oh is that outside nope this is chaos
land
okay good pop
hey where'd it go hey you took it
oh it's got a smiley face that's good
okay road closed i don't believe you
soda please
i need something to get me out of here
ah well this seems easy enough
hey hey
[Music]
oh what the heck
while we respect the unique progress of
every patient
you must understand that it is possible
to completely exhaust your supply of
dreams
thereby entering a state in which you
will not be able to wake up
even with the help of triggering
mechanisms
[Music]
uh how do you exhaust your number of
dreams to the point where you can't wake
up that doesn't necessarily make a lot
of sense but then again this is a video
game so i'm gonna
hey stop that
[Music]
nice bed thank you hi hello
oh what the heck what it what the what
oh okay oh
oh my god
okay i'm just assuming i follow the
arrow till i get another arrow
right
oh i made it hey please listen carefully
for the sound of an alarm clock
which will automatically play if you are
approaching a destabilizing dream weight
what are you saying about my weight what
the hell are you saying about my weight
oh hey
oh
[Music]
oh my goodness
wow oh
no oh
my brain my brain my brain
my david blaine my oh
my blade oh my blade
my brain is pain i've got
pain mainly in the brain oh
my blade my plane
my plane oh
well that's new well i guess that's my
destabilizing dream
weight isn't it
hey how are you doing oh boy
oh that's a lot that's uh oh okay
well time for another beautiful day
insomnia school hey how you doing
everybody am i awake now
did i make it this is highly unusual it
appears you have entered the
sculpt diagnostic framework patients do
not have access to this dream
well here i am
hi
diagnostic warning unrealistic dream
objects may result in dream integrity
fail state states
well i was hoping for that because i
think i want to fail at dreams
just like an ambition of mine
oh oh
wait what the
i'm gonna make you wait no of course i
shouldn't have changed it at all
you're tiny now wait and where there
must be like a hole
somewhere that i can walk through if
it's tiny
right let me go
over here
diagnostic warning paradox prevention
product calls may not be
fully implemented implemented
ah not aha ooh closed come back later
[Music]
maybe
oh oh my god
oh my god what have i done what did i
just do
holy crap what did i just do
oh oh my
oh i have done something bad
oh my god oh what have i done
i am ascending i am ascending
i am ascending i am ascending i am
ascending i'm ascending i'm falling
i'm falling i'm falling
i'm falling i'm falling i goofed it
i goofed it bad i goofed it bad i goofed
it real bad i goofed that
real bad um let's try that again
oh
[Music]
oh that's what i wanted right
oh
[Music]
okay so i'm exploding my dream is and
exploding everywhere
it's all white nothing but white okay
oh hi that's penis-like
very phallic hello i like your chimney
cool uh great
what's this over there though
nothing okay all right i'll go with the
big old penis one
sure hi how are you doing
wow it's very unisonness in here
oh what's that outside oh that's lovely
oh that's real wait a minute what the
hell
wait what
what oh
there i go
oh oh there you go
[Music]
oh ah oh
ah great
oh hello my name is dr glenn pierce
and many years ago i had a dream
i found myself in a place where i
understood that
each of us begins as nothing where
everything i perceived was shaped by
seeing it exactly the way i wanted to
white space all right so the other one
said conception this says deception
what's deception am i being deceptive
so to please
thank you
so is this the essence of creation
so to speak this is the womb of the mind
if you will and you won't you're not
brave enough too
wow oh
am i about to fight shadow link i feel
like i'm about to fight
shadow link is he behind me is he in the
ground
okay sure
hello what's happening
minerals female toads up there we go
well
okay not an exit i don't believe you
great are you hiding an exit right here
i knew it i knew it
wait i saw another one there we go okay
this is fascinating you know i haven't
actually commented much on the game
itself but the game is fascinating
i do like it it's so stylized and it's
still mind-bending
and a couple of the tricks got old but
man it just keeps throwing more stuff at
you
really makes your brain turn inside out
go back to the basics of who you really
are
and who are you i know not
does anybody really i can't reach that i
can't
you douche you douche
you douche i thought i had that
oh yeah thank you i'll take that yeah
this makes sense
yep nothing weird here
[Music]
thank you but in white space
i also faced the greatest challenge i
could imagine
yeah because with a lifetime of life
itself behind me
and all of the weight that it carried i
realized that seeing things the way i
wanted to
was not as easy as it used to be
okay all right that's good to know but
why
but why though probably because we're
buried in our preconceived notions of
how the universe actually is and our
perception is
what we base our reality on and not
necessarily
the truth of it all and that in the mind
there is no
grounding and fundamental things don't
often make
sense
uh oh ah oh it's up to me i thought it
was just
darkness i thought i was just lost in
darkness i don't believe this for a
second i didn't believe you at all
i believe you wow
ah there we go how many times are you
gonna do that to me
how many times hey we're getting some
color at least uh
this way wow
oh wow hey wait a minute hey hold on
here a second
hey hold on hey something ain't right
hey they're messing with me aren't they
they better not be messing with me
i think i'm being messed with
oh i'm outside now
screw you guys screw you i knew i was
being messed with
can't mess with the messer
you're well beyond dreaming now and
further out than
anyone has ever come back from but we
hope that you won't get discouraged
why would that skirt if this is a place
of pure perspective
isn't it also a place where a different
point of view could make
anything possible maybe that while you
came here i don't know why i came here i
came here for a fun time and you know
frankly i'm getting that so i guess it's
all good but at the same time i feel
like i might be lost like in
inception where i'm forever lost within
a dream within a dream
do i have to play chess with myself
oh i'm falling now
hello hi oh i gotta find
the right path okay so that's a path
that's a pat
oh that's not a path well if that's not
a path
oh oh i see oh i see
oh oh okay uh okay
is it only when i'm holding a piece
nope oh it's the piece that it's on
can't oh it's only ground oh
uh-huh i get it now
oh don't don't do that hopscotch
hopscotch i
get it i get it i get it
well i don't trust this didn't trust
that
i bet that would have been the last one
and this uh kind of going on a while
anyway how am i going to do this if i
only have one
[Music]
oh fascinating
all right okay
[Music]
huh whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
that's cool that's pretty cool that's
pretty cool
uh yeah that's pretty cool weird
oh my goodness oh my goodness
oh my word oh don't look don't look away
don't look away from the path the path
before you is all you need
oh my mama hi
hello
oh
okay oh my goodness 729
and 730.
oh oh no eight 759
i didn't read that right
wakey wakey eggs and bakey
a suspiciously normal loading bar
ah what a beautiful day
oh
the hell okay
hello my name is dr glenn pierce
and by now you may have realized that
all of this has happened exactly the way
it was supposed to
you see everyone who comes to the
institute does so because they feel
that they are no longer in control of
something
[Music]
yeah now i feel super in control boss
yo my main not man
problem is not that the problems we face
can't be solved
the problem is that we become so afraid
of failure
that we refuse to see our problems from
a new perspective
and so we do the same things again and
again
and again and then of course
we find exactly the failure we were
looking for
okay
i mean yeah that makes sense i got
nothing to argue against that
makes perfect sense
[Music]
oh hi
my soda
your life will always be a struggle and
you will always have problems
but today you have the chance to see
things differently
even though it meant facing obstacles
that seemed impossible at first
you thought outside the box and you
overcame them
because you saw things from every angle
you understood them
for what they really were because you
kept moving forward
no matter how far off the path you were
told you were headed
or how unexpected it became you
found your way damn you
quite profound
that's quite nice to think about
i like that i like that a lot
i was pretty sure this game was going
for something like that
in terms of its message but you know
that's really nice
it is really nice i like that a lot
in a few minutes you'll be back in the
real world and some parts of you will
say that
none of this was real so how could it
have really meant anything
but just like the power of perspective
itself
it will have been as real as you
believed it to be
all you've got to do is wake
up that's a good point
that was really cool that was
really really cool as far as like
gameplay goes
it's obviously a game based on gimmicks
and tricks of perception
but i loved that they tied it all into
unified story
and that's what really makes it
something special that's what takes
just gimmicks to a game
and like art and and stuff like that
it's elevating with a message
with like a core reasoning and you can
feel the reasoning in the developer and
you can feel what they were really going
for
and i loved this like this was super fun
it was towards the end i was getting a
little like okay
all right i get it yeah but you know i i
think it was good to have a
short experience that like went through
arcs in terms of like i loved the
scary section and i loved that there
really wasn't anything scary about it it
was just all in your head
it's like that's really what it's all
about what it's trying to say is like
the way you view
a problem or an issue or even just
information in the world is all based on
how like how you respond to it is based
on your perspective and everyone has
different perspectives
everyone is either literally seeing it
from a different perspective or
you know based on their previous
experiences in their life
they have preconceived notions about
what their perspective is i have the
hiccups now
but this is great i really enjoyed this
i hope you did too
and if you want to buy the game yourself
you can get it up on steam even though
i played it here i think i'm but
oh my god if i could have likes but here
comes she'll be cute if enough people
subscribe and ring the bell
for more hiccups i will never lose my
hips
it's so profound i can't my body's
spasming to try to reject the profundity
of it i'm gonna
die here okay
but good very good pillow castle great
stuff love the name that's a good one
so thank you everybody so much for
watching
if you want to see more awesome games i
got a playlist down in the description
below
for dream is this old dream maybe it was
all reality you'll only be able to
find out by ringing the bell and waking
yourself up so ring that bell
for more dreams i'm gonna die i'll see
you around guys uh
take care you have lovely life
they're gone
[Music]
you